>>Roni Zeiger: Hello everyone.
Thanks for being here.
It’s a pleasure to be back at Google.
My name is Roni Zeiger.
I was here for about six years until just
a couple weeks ago.
And, uh, it’s especially sweet to get to
present, uh, to introduce a friend, Eric Topol,
who, um, is actually a little bit of a hero
to me.
I won’t get to weepy don’t worry.
[Laughter]
>>Roni Zeiger: But he’s um, he’s a professor
of translational genomics at the Scripps institute,
south of here, also director of that institute.
He’s also the co-founder, um, of the West
Wireless Institute down in San Diego.
He’s also a cardiologist.
And, if you’re starting to get a sense that
this guy is, um, sort of a rocket scientist
and a brain surgeon, he’s almost all of those
things.
Um, he, uh, he’s been central in developing
a lot of medications, um, and other technologies
that many of us in the field of medicine take
for granted and use every day.
And, perhaps most importantly, if someone
asks for a doctor on an airplane, Eric will
not only volunteer, but he’ll bring his iPhone,
put it on their chest and get a cardiogram.
So, so this is a guy that you really want
to travel with.
[Laughter]
>>Roni Zeiger: So, let’s go on a, on a journey
with him now.
[Applause]
>>Eric Topol: Great!
Thanks, thanks a lot.
Okay.
It’s great to be here with you.
Great to be at Google, I’ve never been here
before.
And, uh, well it should be fun.
I know maybe because so many people are young
here, they’re not so into their health or
the health world.
But, those of you that are here, I hope will
have an interesting, uh, informative experience.
I’ll certainly enjoy it.
So first, I put this quote up because I thought
that would set the tone for what we’re gonna
talk about during this hour.
And this is a Voltaire 250 years ago, and
I’m afraid it’s not much different today.
And, uh, the whole notion that doctors are
doing things with good intentions but they
don’t have the information.
And, that’s going to change very quickly.
So, there’s a very noted, uh, very famous
Austrian economist whose name was Joseph Schumpeter
and he, uh , was responsible for the idea
that great innovation in an economy with entrepreneurship
could change an economy and that graph of
old economy going to new economy shown here.
And this term of creative destruction is really
credited for having pushed forward, and that’s
what I think applies to the opportunities
in medicine and health care and that’s really
an exciting thing that we can do.
So, since Schumpeter is one of my heroes,
I was really surprised when I was reading
the Economist, my favorite weekly read, reading
the Schumpeter column, this is just a week
ago.
And I’m looking at this column saying, “Oh,
now for some good news.” I have no idea what
it was gonna be about.
Then I found out it was a book review.
This book, uh, and it was very positive about
a godsend for those that suffer from Armageddon
fatigue.
So hopefully you will find this to be a very
upbeat experience as the viewer did there.
And, of course, the Economist is interesting
'cause they don’t, they’re unsigned.
So I don’t even know who Schumpeter is on
the Economist.
But, um, what were gonna talk about is, how
digitizing human beings, which is what generates
this remarkable information, is going to reboot
the future of medicine.
And, before I get into that topic, 'cause
that’s really how we can do this, I wanted
to get a sense of how many of you are on Twitter
here.
Everybody?
Not everybody, but the majority.
See, most times when I talk, the people who
are really worried about their health, happen
to be at least 50, 60, 70, and they don’t
even know Twitter exists, for the most part.
This is a different group, and it’s fun to
talk to folks who are more plugged in.
I get most of my valuable information from
Twitter.
I’ll show you a couple of slides that I made
this morning, through Twitter.
So that’s, kinda for me, a, a, great reservoir,
if everybody shares their, their information
that they get to, with everyone else interested
in a particular space, it’s great.
So, I wanna convince you of three things.
The first one hopefully will be the easiest,
because we’re here at a, a, major force that’s
done this.
Our world has been Schumpetered.
The second is that medicine is going to go
there, and it’s just started now.
The third is that we need consumers to drive
this whole thing forward, because otherwise,
uh, at least some of us will not be around
to see it.
And, I certainly want to see this thing take
hold, and improve the whole way we render,
uh, prevention and healthcare in the future.
So, I wanna start off on the digital side
of this… and that’s your kind of comfort
zone I know…on zero-one and just to point
out, and I think you’re very well aware of
this, in the last decade there was just a
remarkable jump forward, the likes of which
we’ve never seen.
And, of course, in the, uh, in context for
example, there are now more cell phones on
the planet than there are toilets or toothbrushes.
That’s a pretty big, uh, thing that who would
ever had th--, when Marty Cooper invented
the cell phone in 1973, who would ever of
thought that would actually happen, and so
quickly, particularly in the last decade.
And then these devices have been remarkably
transformative.
And, the span of time from the iPod in 01’,
all the way through, uh, the Blackberry then
was renamed crack berry, now more recently
slack berry.
Then there’s iPhones, prototype phone.
And, of course, I guess here I should have
put a Droid phone up there, but, sorry about
that.
Then there’s the EBooks and, uh, the Tablets.
And this is nine years.
And these devices and I’m looking around
thinking, “Well how come you’re not looking
at your device right now, because you’re
basically surgically attached to them?” And
you’re giving me the great privilege of a
few minutes of attention, before you delve
right into your mobile devices.
So they’ve been very remarkably transformative.
And, in fact, everything that we do, well
beyond how we communicate, uh, how we think
and behave has been very much influenced by
these wireless devices.
In fact, when you think about that, if life
could have changed so quickly in this span
of nine years, how come it couldn’t do that
in the medical sphere?
And that really got me thinking.
So, in fact, this current issue of the Economist,
um, uh, is this article, this Schumpeter column,
“Slave to the smartphone.” I don’t know
if you think you’re a slave, I certainly
feel I’m an eSlave to the smartphone or tablet.
Because there’s so much information coming
in and you certainly want to try to communicate
with your, with your network.
So, what’s going on now is that it’s not;
it isn’t even just one screen that we are
attached to; it’s now become multiple screens.
And, now it’s a tablet, it’s a PC, a computer,
it’s a smartphone.
And now we have a new species of man, a Homo
Distractus.
As demonstrated here, a Homo Distractus has
a new add on feature, cause later this year
I understand there’s gonna be these Google
glasses.
And I haven’t seen exactly what they are
and this is one speculate of design of them,
but if you really have augmented reality,
uh, as well as being able to potentially read
things, uh, from the web or your e-mail from
your glasses, that’s gonna be yet another
screen to, uh, to add to the Homo Distractus.
It starts at a very young age, uh, this whole
process.
So, you’re not so far removed from that.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: And, I uh thought that was pretty
young, when I looked at that, and then I didn’t’
realize it’s actually starting at an even
younger age as shown here.
And so, this is a, I think, a phenomena that’s
very, very interesting.
And I know that so many of you are digital
neighbors here, the vast majority, so you
can appreciate that for those of us who’ve
had to learn this whole world in the mid-stream
of our lives, has been much more challenging.
So there’s some questions I’m going to ask
you, and they’re obvious, but I’ll ask them
anyway.
Uh, but, I wanted to give you a sense of time
compression.
So what was zero in 2004, and then was 800
million in 2010, was?
>>Eric Topol: I know you know the answer to
this.
>>male #1: I think it was the number of users.
>>Eric Topol: Yeah.
There you go.
OK, I like that answer.
So, that of course, represents a competitor.
But, you’re well aware that that’s gonna
be about a billion, unless there’s an awful
lot of defriending that occurs between now
and then.
To go to Google plus, or I don’t know what.
Uh, or just abandon social networking, which
I think is most unlikely.
Of course, the evaluation of this company
is predicated on the like button and this
is a beginning of a social network dedicated
company of digitizing people.
We’ve been doing that for a long time, at
Google, much longer.
What year was Google founded?
>>Eric Topol: Ninety…ninety eight?
Anybody know here?
‘98.
Ok, so you’ve been in this world of digitizing
people, in some respect, for a long time.
And of course, the worst thing that could
happen is you wake up and you don’t have
any friends.
That’d probably be good if you were trying
to, uh, promote your social network.
But these companies, your company, Facebook,
Amazon, Apple, have done an extraordinary
job of digitizing people at a very superficial
level, not medical, of course.
We’ll get into some exceptions of that.
But, what it shows is that you can collect
some data.
And this, of course, can be very important
for, uh, individuals likes and affinities
and important for, uh, consumer engagement
and purchasing and that sort of thing.
But, the way to this goes is medical, and
that’s where this can go over time.
So I thought you might have seen this article,
perhaps, in the Atlantic, uh, just a couple
weeks ago.
About, uh, I’m being followed, how Google
and 104 other companies are tracking me on
the web.
Have you seen, or read that article?
Yeah?
No?
You don’t, anyways it’s a very interesting
article.
It talks about how no matter what you’re
going to get digitized, essentially.
Not using those terms.
And then this other feature article in the
New York Times magazine, was about, uh, the
idea that the retail, it’s not just Google
and 104 other companies that are, that are
set up to do this, but in fact there’s Target
and all the retail companies that are doing
this.
And so they know, for example, a woman is
pregnant before her family even knows that
she’s pregnant because of the data that can
be, uh, acquired.
So I thought you might enjoy this if you hadn’t
already seen it.
This is how to protect yourself from getting
digitized by Google.
Um, have you all seen this already?
I saw this and I broke out in hysterical laughter.
Because something I said, “oh my gosh, play
the music loud so they can’t hear what you’re
typing, unplug computer from power source,
medical gloves to obscure fingerprints and
finger scans on keys.” You know, but obviously
this isn’t just applying to Google, this
is applying to the fact that you may be getting
digitized to some extent.
And you don’t really have a way, all these
things are not gonna work, of course.
So, that’s the way life is today.
Then there’s this social network.
This is uh, of course, zero in 2006, zero.
Now two years later after the beginning of
Facebook, and now well over 300 million per
day.
And you know what that is?
That’s the number of?
>>Audience member: [inaudible]
>>Eric Topol: Somebody said it.
Yeah.
So, that is of course part.
Now the big three, perhaps in the US, um,
but there’s all these other social networks
around the world and are, of course, many
of them are country, continent specific.
You know, there’s Brazil with Orkut, then
there’s QQ in China, and that sort of thing.
Well this together, has created a force that
no one could’ve predicted.
And, you know, I think when Eric Schmidt said,
we missed the friend thing, we all missed
the friend thing, it wasn’t just at Google.
But now this friend thing with sharing pictures,
and emotions, and thoughts, and videos, has
had, of course, monstrous, uh, phenomenal
impact.
And that’s why revolutions have occurred,
the Arab Spring, the Occupy Wall Street movement
and so many other things are power to the
people by crowd cheering, crowd activating,
and crowd sourcing, really a remarkable time
in our history and in our civilization because
of this electronic bounty of people.
So, this is an example of a rudimentary social
network that has had a medical impact.
And this is, uh, as far as we know, the first
person on Facebook, who’s punitively, his
life was saved, a young boy who was very sick
and, uh, he couldn’t get a diagnosis.
He went to two pediatricians and then, uh,
his mother posted his picture on Facebook,
and one of her Facebook friends made the diagnosis
of Kawasaki’s disease.
And that’s what led to, uh, the right treatment
and of course he’s doing very well.
And now, there are, uh, an explosion of these
online health communities.
And this is a good thing, but it’s also been
an awakening because now so many people with
a chronic condition, whether it be diabetes
or, or a type of cancer or things like multiple
sclerosis, they go on these patient’s like
me and other communities, uh, together, they
find people with the same condition, and now
these virtual peers become the people who
they trust the most.
They’ve never met them, but they trust them
much more than their doctors.
Which is really a uh, in many ways, a seismic
shake up of the relationship between doctors
and patients.
And so much so, that this to me is shocking,
this is nearly 4,000 doctors who were polled,
as to, “do you know that there’s these things,
like patients like me?” And only 11% and
this is recent just a few months ago.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: Only 11% even knew they existed.
But if they talked to their patients, they
would find that that’s who their patients
are spending their time with and getting guidance.
So that shows you the chasm that exists today
between the medical profession and what the
needs are and the access, the capabilities,
of empowered consumers who want to get this
information.
Now, I know you’re gonna get this one right.
Right?
This is the one group that could get this
one right.
What does this represent?
>>Eric Topol: Nobody knows?
Really?
Okay, it’s at the San Diego Zoo, does that
help you?
>>Eric Topol: No?
Okay, I’m really surprised.
This is historically very significant.
This is the first YouTube ever video.
Ok when was that?
April 2005.
Well over 6 million hits.
Now, why is this important?
It’s a stupid video, it just says, “Here
I am at the San Diego Zoo!” Alright?
But, the point is that this is just not even
seven years ago and look at the data for YouTube.
Okay?
This is an amazing thing.
800 million unique users per month, 3 billion
views per day, 3 trillion hours of video per
month.
I mean this is staggering, 60 hours of video
are uploaded every minute.
What are we doing sitting here?
We should be watching a video or uploading
or both.
So this is an amazing amount of data in this
video and graphic world that we live in.
And so much so, that we are generating data
at a clip which no one could ever have forecasted.
That is from the beginning of civilization
to 2003, there were only a billion gigabytes,
which is kind of amazing because we walk around
with lots of gigabytes in our pocket.
And now we are generating a trillion gigabytes,
a zettabyte, at least one, every year that
plot of course, is markedly increasing.
And that’s why it looks like we’ll have
well over 35 zettabytes by the end of just
this decade.
So that creates a big problem with data, especially
when you wanna extract out of that data, the
useful information that has heretofore often
been only scratching the surface.
And this big data term, is terribly underplaying
the ginormity of this data issue.
But, just like Moneyball, um, we can have
this in medicine; we can learn a lot more
about a particular pitcher or batter by doing
a lot more work on that data.
And we’d like to learn a lot more about each
individual.
Prevent them from becoming a patient, by doing
this sort of thing.
How are we going to do that in this world
of just, ginormous data flooding?
Well, the super computer of Watson has been,
uh, and other super computers, has been suggested
to be able to save a life.
And, of course the reason for that is that
because a super computer, Watson, can process
two million pages of content in 3 seconds.
Now, there are a lot of really good doctors
out there, but I don’t think they can get
to two million pages of content in 3 seconds.
And if you have a really complex patient,
that you don’t know what’s going on, like
what happened with WellPoint, one of the largest
insurers, they decided to contract Watson,
because then they could feed all the, get
all the information about a new individual
patient to help sort out in a complex diagnosis.
That’s a good thing.
Why don’t all doctors, and all patients,
have access to a super computer in times of
need.
That’s where things will go, eventually.
Then there’s the cloud, of course.
The cloud story, which is amazing, it’s important
that this of course emerged these massive
server farms because otherwise we wouldn’t
be able to store, or even, um, handle, manipulate
some of this data.
So what’s great about the cloud is now it’s
even making its way to places like United
Health.
And recently they have, uh, just last month,
uh, declared they’re gonna make their cloud
data, which is their largest private insurer
of health in the United States, available
to all their doctors and soon to all their
patients who are covered by United Health.
That’s a step in the right direction.
But this cloud thing is so overcooked, that
I thought these cartoons might help put it
in perspective.
This one is the check is in the cloud, and
the other one, it was much nicer before people
started storing all their personal information
in the cloud.
Ok, so now we have this kind of rapid fire,
it started in the 70’s, it wasn’t so rapid
then, the cell phone I mentioned, the personal
computer, the internet.
And then things really started taking off.
And you see this, uh, clustering.
In a short period of time of wireless digital
devices, sequencing social networks, cloud
and super- computing, all setting up the potential
for this, uh, era of a great inflection in
medicine.
And that’s where I’m gonna be, of course,
trying to convince you, that we’re on the
cusp of that right now.
Of really, uh, actualizing that opportunity.
So, book stores and books, there’s a really
interesting story there.
How many of you only read books as an E-book?
>>Eric Topol: No.
One?
Two?
I guess, three.
Alright.
And how many will read only hard copy books?
>>Eric Topol: Ok, four.
Ok, so should I assume that the rest don’t
read any books or read a combination of the
two?
Help me on that.
>>Audience: Combination.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: Combina—Okay.
Okay.
Anyway, that’s alright, if you don’t read
any books, you have a lot of other things
to do I understand.
Um, so, the reason I show this, of course,
that there’s a prediction that hard copy
books are gonna be no longer with us.
And, of course, we’ve seen the likes of things
like Borders Book Store chain of book stores
closing.
Well, today is a big day.
Today is the day on the front page of The
New York Times, The Encyclopedia Britannica,
after 244 years, that’s the same time when
Voltaire were saying that we didn’t know
anything about medicine.
244 years later, The Encyclopedia Britannica,
is mea culpa, we’re not going to print this
thing anymore, ever again.
That’s pretty striking.
That’s today.
And, to me, the final thing about this book,
I’m using the book thing as to, uh, emblematic
of the world changing.
I could go into all sorts of other things,
but this is the one, I think, that really
hits home for me.
I did some of my training, my cardiology training,
at John’s Hopkins.
And John’s Hopkins has this library that
I lived at a lot, called the Welch Medical
Library.
And this library was closed on January 1st,
the second largest medical library in this
country, no longer functional.
Does that tell you a story about where we
are in a changing world?
In a world that’s been Schumpetered.
So I hope I’ve convinced you of that fact
in this opening segment.
And if I haven’t, then this probably would
be a good time to move on because it’s the
best I can do, in this time span.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: Okay.
Now we’re gonna talk about medicine and how
it will, inevitably, be Schumpetered.
Because up until now, the digital macrocosm
ginormous infrastructure, that’s been developed,
which I’ve very briefly reviewed with you,
that you’re very much, uh, in touch with.
Then there’s this medical microcosm cocoon
that’s done everything possible to not let
there be any conversions, or any penetration
of the digital world.
The only foray into that has been this very
weak lack of, uh, real legs, use of electronic
health records, and, of course, accounting
for the difficulties that you experience with
Google health records, and that sort of thing,
because it’s so resistant to the digital
world.
Well, that’s gonna change.
And this is all gonna come together.
There will be a conversion it’s just a matter
of when.
And when that happens, there’s a big, big
thing, that we’ve never had before, and that’s
the ability to digitize man, digitize human
beings.
Not to find out what they’ve purchased now,
or what they will purchase.
But rather, what makes them tick.
And that’s really an exciting thing.
That takes us away from where we are in medicine
today, which is at the population level.
Everything we do is population based.
So, for example, when we say all women after
age 40 should have a mammogram every year,
that’s treating all people the same.
When in fact, many woman, a significant portion,
have zero risk of ever developing breast cancer.
Another example, we give a medicine for a
particular condition, let’s say diabetes,
we use Metformin.
There’s 400 million diabetics on the planet,
they get the same drug, the same dose, even
though 25% of them are unable to respond to
that drug.
But that’s how medicine is practiced today.
We do large clinical trials of thousands of
patients, we find a few per hundred benefit,
and then everyone gets the drug.
That’s wrong, totally dead wrong.
And now, for the first time, we have the tools
to understand things at the individual level.
And that’s extraordinary.
And that’s what we’re gonna get into.
So, uh, Thomas Goetz, the editor of Wired
magazine, wrote this really brilliant feature
article in that magazine about the feedback
loop, and the whole point here is, it’s a
feedback loop of data where there’s genomic
data or physiologic metric data, I’ll show
you a couple of examples.
And that changes things.
That’s like a real reset of how we understand
any given individual.
>>Eric Topol: So, this started in the healthcare
world.
Uh, fitness world I should say.
Whereby, uh, Nike shoes, I don’t know how
many of you have these Nike plus shoes that
have sensors in the sole of the foot and they
can track the distance and the velocity and
other metrics of exercise.
And then these wireless accelerometers, have
any of you tried things like the FIT Big BodyMedia?
You have?
Okay, great.
So those are, I recommend them to my patients
because they encourage you to be more active.
And, uh, um, I think that, that’s a great
thing.
They’re relatively inexpensive.
The most recent one, was just um, uh, announced
a little over a week ago, the Nike FuelBand.
And so they encourage people to be more active,
that’s good.
And then there’s the use of sensors for detecting
your quality of sleep, because we live in
this wired world of wireless devices.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: And we don’t get enough sleep.
In fact, the overall sleep of the population
has been declining in a very, uh, worrisome
pattern.
So there’s a device that I’ve used, there
are many devices that monitor sleep this is
the only one that monitors brain waves.
And this is a new device, have any of you
ever used it here?
>>Eric Topol: So we got the same 3 people
that have used all these sensors, okay.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: That’s alright.
Someday your, your experience will wear off
on the others here.
Anyway, this is a great, uh, home electroencephalogram.
Who would have ever thought you could have
your brain waves at home, for $99, going directly
to your phone, pretty neat.
And, uh, there’s also a clock version, which
is what they came out with originally, and
it shows right on the clock every minute of
sleep.
This is a night of my sleep.
You see the orange bars are the awake time,
the grey bars are light sleep which isn’t
worth much, the light green bars are the dream
rapid eye movement sleep which is a good thing.
And then the best of all is deep restorative
sleep, the dark green .So I’m using this
and, uh, I’m trying to get to be a better
sleeper and very shortly after I started using
this, my wife who is a night owl, comes in
the room and she looks at the clock and she
says, “Eric, I know you’re awake, and I
wanna talk.”
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: Ok.
And that’s good that people at this age can
appreciate that, because that’s, of course,
one of those kinds of things that, uh, you
would particularly appreciate getting older.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: Anyway, what’s interesting
is, uh, you also know, of course when anybody’s,
their brain is awake.
And besides, this was discovered by three,
Brown university college students.
They didn’t wanna do this.
What they wanted to do was not to have to
be woken up out of a deep sleep.
So they invented this sensor, just so they
wouldn’t have to wake up, they wanted only
to be woken up when they were in a light sleep.
And that’s what led to this interesting device.
Well, of course, when the Wall Street Journal
reviewed this book, the Creative Destruction
book, but what was really interesting they
picked this as the call out for the article
which was kind of I didn’t think that was
the most significant statement in the book.
But it was kind of interesting that they did
that.
Now, what was also, uh, interesting is that
it’s representative of where medicine is
going, because now you have data for your
sleep, compared to ten thousand people of
your age group, your peer group, because as
you likely know, as we get older, our sleep
deteriorates, and so you want to have a group
that you compare with.
And just think about glucose, that’s blood
pressure or any metric that’s relevant in
medicine so you can compare.
And now what’s really interesting is that
this has become a big fad in, among athletes.
And so knowing your DQ score of your sleep,
now there’s triathletes that are using this,
there’s three NBA teams that are currently
using Zeo every night to maximize their athletic
performance.
And so this is now a very safe way, as opposed
to other historic ways, that athletes would
try to improve their performance.
Well what’s also interesting is that now
among pro athletes there’s a compilation
of all the data of pro athletes.
And this is a, uh, bar graph that, uh, summarizes
it.
The King of sleep among all the pro athletes
is LeBron James averaging 12 hours of sleep
a night.
And what’s interesting is, no wonder they’ve
never won the playoffs.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: And then, the other interesting
facet of this is the person with the very
least sleep is Tiger Woods.
And I’m not gonna comment further on that.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: Now, there are, um, very, uh,
kind of early staged devices now that you
can get your blood pressure that are fun.
It doesn’t quite gamify things, but it does
make it a lot more fun.
So now my patients, instead of recommending
the traditional blood pressure cuff, called
an Omron device, that go to Cosco, I now send
them to iHealth or Withings to order it online,
again, $99.
These things are fun, you just press the button,
gets the blood pressure, it charts it, it
sends it to your doctor or your Facebook friends
or your Google plus circles, whatever.
And then you have it all stored.
And then you, uh, have it all stored.
And the same thing for glucose, that’s a
good thing.
That’s not where we want it to be, we want
it to be seamless, but that’s at least a
step in the right direction.
Well, this is also the case for diabetes.
For, uh, Type1, also called insulin- dependent
juvenile diabetes, we can measure glucose
every 5 minutes.
But currently, there’s separate receiver,
it’s bulky.
If you’re a diabetic, you don’t want to
have this big device to be pulling out all
the time because then people would say, “What’s
the matter with you?” You gotta tell them,
“Well, I have diabetes I’m looking at my
glucose.” What I have is a prototype that
I’m wearing a sensor just like pictured on
this, on this slide.
Uh, you can wear it on your abdomen, or your
arm or wherever.
And I can just turn on my phone and, uh, I
can see it when I turn it on 137 and I can
just say my glucose at this very moment in
time is 10.
And that’s good since we just ate lunch at
your cafeteria with the unlimited buffet.
I’m glad it’s not a lot higher than that.
But what’s also nice is I can just, um, get
the data for the trend for, you know, here’s
the three hour trend for glucose, six hours,
twelve hours, 24, whatever I want.
And I can send it, if I’m concerned, to whoever
I wanted to send it to.
That’s the beginning of an exciting time
for example, lifestyle improvement, if you’re
looking at something, should you eat it or
not, and you’re looking at your phone and
it’s gonna tell you what your glucose is
gonna do when you eat this big cookie.
Well, you might not eat the cookie because
you don’t want to stress out your pancreas.
Particularly if you know that you’re pre-diabetic,
or you’re genomicaly vulnerable to get diabetes.
Now, Roni mentioned this in the intro is that
this is a device, that, uh, I can get, uh,
I gotta pull up my iPhone.
But this is the device where I can get a cardiogram,
right on the device.
And so, it’s, you see these two sensors on
the back; you make a circuit with your heart
like that.
And so, um, you know, this pops into the case.
I can then just turn this thing on and get
a cardiogram, just gotta um, um, put in, uh,
my password and the app.
Get that ready and then I’ll just show you,
that here’s my, put my fingers on the back
and then we’ll pop up my cardiogram.
Now, it’s really a cool device, because,
you say, “My gosh, why wasn’t this invented
tens of years ago?” And what’s also pretty
cool is that I have this credit card version,
where you can put it in your wallet or you
can put it in your purse has the same two
sensors.
And then you can hear the chest leads, I don’t
know if you’ve ever had a cardiogram but
you can get the different leads, like this.
And that’s what you heard about being on
a plane, it actually happened, where someone
in the last row was having chest pain, they
called for a doctor on the plane; there were
three other doctors who were surgeons that
don’t really know how to evaluate chest pain.
And I don’t know if I’d know how to evaluate
it fully unless I had a cardiogram.
And, uh, this is, you know, at 30,000 feet.
You don’t have a cardiogram to do.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: But, now I have it and I can
say this person was having a bona fide large
heart attack.
And that led to an emergency landing of the
plane.
And also, when we landed, and the, the passenger
was whisked off to get the artery, the heart
attack artery opened up.
Then the pilots and the flight attendants
all wanted to have their cardiogram done.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: Which was really interesting.
Okay.
So, those are just a couple of devices to
show you, to give you a sense of how this
field is moving fast.
And, you know, they’re actually getting old
now, there are a lot of other devices I couldn’t
bring with me today to give you a sense.
This one is really interesting, the Holter
monitor.
You probably don’t know what that Is, but
this was invented in 1949 with a frozen design.
And you have to wear all these wires to find
out your heart rhythm over the course of 24
hours.
You have to go in and get it connected, then
you have to go to a clinic, then you have
to go back to get it disconnected.
You can’t shower, you can’t exercise.
Now you have band aid, you send it in the
mail, you send it back.
It’s a Netflix model of heart rhythm monitoring.
Okay and it’s great.
But, you know, it’s only happened in recent
months that this was available.
And then, just to, uh, give you a little bit
of more sense about what you can monitor on
a phone this is all the vital signs.
Not just blood pressure, but also your oxygen
in your blood, concentration, your blood pressure,
heart rhythm, temperature.
And, you know, this is an amazing ability
to basically have all vital signs on your
phone continuously.
So your phone in the future will look like
this.
This is technically feasible today.
And it will get your constant read out of
all your vital signs.
As if you were in an intensive care unit.
Now you may not want to look at that data
or have that, but it certainly will be interesting
to see how that plays out and how it can help
prevent people from having to be in the hospital.
In fact, I think there won’t be hospitals
in the future, except for intensive care units.
Why would there be a hospital when you can
do all this stuff at a patient’s home?
And it’s much less expensive, much more comfortable.
So why, eventually, are we gonna need hospitals
except for very limited reasons.
Now, just some other apps to mention that
are useful.
If you’re, um, for someone who has a skin
lesion that you’re worried about, you don’t
have to go to the dermatologist anymore.
You just get a picture done, text within minutes
saying not to worry, or you should indeed
get this looked into.
And then, this one is amazing, if you’re
an optometrist, you better watch out because
now there’s a $2 add on to the phone, it
was invented at MIT, that gets refraction
of your eyes and then sends that data to your,
uh, to get your glasses made, for $2, pretty
remarkable.
And then you can pass it around for all your
friends, and your social network.
And it’s not, of course, being used that
much in the US but its sure getting likes
around the world.
And this, just speaking of eyes, there’s
ways to monitor the pressure in the eye, to
prevent glaucoma.
This is available in Europe, constant monitoring
going to your phone.
And then there’s these things like a Wheeze-o-meter
that analyzes your breathing to prevent an
asthma attack.
And then this morning, I, I encountered that
there is another, uh, interesting facet to
asthma.
This was reported that there’s this smart
inhaler, most people, when they use an inhaler
they use it wrong.
And now there’s a video game to make you
use it right.
And that’s really part of this gamification
of medical devices.
It’s all part of this new era of medicine.
There’s also the ability to digitize breath,
to say whether or not someone might have lung
cancer, at a pretty high specificity and accuracy.
So, you’re competitor, Apple, has certainly
been seen, like Google, as a big innovator.
And so, in fact, at the time of Steve Jobs’
death, it was thought well may the logo should
be changed, and of course, like you, this
company has had a big worldwide impact.
And I thought you particularly might enjoy
this one if you haven’t seen it.
This is the cover of The New Yorker.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: And then another company cartoon.
>>Eric Topol: Well, in this biography, which
I don’t know if any of you have read here.
Some of you may have read, I think it’s a
very good book.
But I’m particularly, because it traces a
digital revolution over the course of really
three decades.
Took a while for it to be where it is today,
but it’s now, of course, going in exponential
fashion.
And then what was striking to me is this quote,
because it was occurring near the end of the
book.
And it said, from Steve Jobs, “I think the
biggest innovations of the 21st century will
be the intersection of biology and technology.”
That’s where you sit today in a digital frontier,
and this is the big uncharted opportunity,
and I certainly couldn’t agree more that
this is the real story going forward.
So now we just touch on the one aspect that
is really biology.
We were talking about physiology, but let’s
get into a little bit of biology and that
is genome sequencing.
>>Eric Topol: Up until now, in the recent
years, we’ve been relying on these next generation
sequencers that cost ¾ of a million dollars.
And then a whole lot more expense for the
re agents that are proprietary to run the
sequence.
The six billion letters that comprise a human
genome that has to be sequenced 40 times,
at least, to be accurate.
Well, in January, this device, the ion and
proton, was released and it said that it could
sequence the human genome in two hours, prior
to this and still today it takes us about
ten days.
Dropping down from ten days to two hours?
That’s pretty good.
Well then this device last month was released.
This is a USB size device.
This is now to get a sequence of a human genome
in 15 minutes, for less than $1000.
In fact, it’s quoted as $900.
This is, uh, exceeded Moore’s law at a level
that is unprecedented, uh, you know, in our
history.
And so what’s exciting about this is how
you can apply it.
And you’ve been hearing about the human genome
since 2000, if you’ve been at least looking
into this impact on the future of our world.
But, you know, this is a sequence you can
get right to your laptop.
Then you can take a boy like this, whose life
was saved by sequencing.
Nicholas Volker.
At this point he was nearly going to die.
He had 100 operations.
I don’t know any human being that’s had
100 operations, no less a 5-year-old.
And he was very sick in the hospital intensive
care, in a hyperbaric chamber.
His pediatrician said, “Let’s sequence him
and see what is potentially this disease we’ve
never seen in a human being before.” And
that led to a finding the mutation that was
the root cause, and that let to successful
treatment.
And now Nicholas Volker is healthy as could
be, cured 6-year-old.
And that’s a great story because it tells
you the power of sequencing.
Telling you, digitizing a human being who
is so sick that no one knows what it is, and
be able to turn that around into having, hopefully,
with this young boy, a normal life.
This is a family from San Diego, the Beery
family.
Uh, and so, these twins, Alexis and Noah,
were very sick.
They had a movement disorder, they couldn’t
really function.
In fact, Alexis was in the emergency room,
she couldn’t even breath many times, she
had a respiratory arrest.
And so they got sequenced.
They determined the cause.
They determined the right therapy.
And now Noah is a soccer star and his sister
is a track star, just by sequencing.
This is a protocol that we have at Scripps,
called IDIOM.
IDIOM, it stands for idiopathic diseases of
man.
That’s a terrible term, idiopathic.
It’s a fancy medical term for we don’t know,
idiopathic.
Why don’t we just say, “We don’t know?”
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: Anyway, this is a 15-year-old
girl, who is wheelchair bound, who’s brilliant.
Blogs and is cheerful.
But, she has an unknown condition, and we’re
sequencing her along with other individuals
right now, trying to digitize their biology
so we can get the root cause and hopefully
it will prove to be actionable.
So we wanna get rid of this term idiopathic,
it’s a bad term anyway, but it’s also one
that we can get rid of because we can sequence
people and understand what is really going
on.
Then there’s of course the cancer war that
was declared decades ago.
But now, it’s the real deal.
We can actually do something in cancer.
This is an example of a tumor called malignant
melanoma metastatic.
Skin cancer all over the body and this is
a PET scan that shows the extent of the burden
of cancer, and then two weeks later, after
an oral pill directed to the mutation, that
was causing this cancer, a BRAF gene which
is present in about 2/3 of people with this
type of cancer, there was no evidence of any
cancer.
And this occurs in 85% of people, who have
this type of mutation, in this particular
cancer.
So it’s a great step forward and it shows
you the power of knowing what is the root
cause of a cancer.
And then having a therapy directed towards
it.
Here’s another example of a different drug
that just got approved.
But this is another basal cell carcinoma or
brain cancer.
Medulla blastoma, two weeks later specific
against this hedgehog gene pathway and then
you have no evidence of cancer in over 85%
of people just to prove.
The problem we have in cancer today, is to
do this, we like to have, uh, the tissue to
be able to sequence.
In fact, get a whole genome sequence.
But today, the tumor specimen from a biopsy
or a surgery is deposited into formaldehyde
and it’s ruined.
So we’d like that on track to just being
FF, which is flash frozen.
So that needs some work.
But this cancer improvement, in getting people
to get the right therapy, is on the way.
And then beyond the whole area of cancer there
is many conditions like cystic fibrosis, we’ve
known the gene for many years, but finally
have a breakthrough.
This is a drug called Kalydeco which is just
approved, it’s directed against a specific
mutation that causes cystic fibrosis and only
is accounting for, let’s say, 3 or 4% of
cystic fibrosis.
But it’s very potent and works exceptionally
well.
And then this young girl, who couldn’t breathe
hardly at all, she now is, as you see, uh,
very mobile and living a normal life.
And this drug, as I mentioned, not only did
it just get approved, but it had eureka effect.
In terms of normalizing things like so called
sweat chloride and beyond that, even more
importantly, that you could see the impact,
the breathing, the placebo sugar pill versus
the drug.
And here you just see a weight gain of kids,
just dramatic, uh, eureka type effect, which
is great to see in a small number of people.
This is a pretty gory slide, but what is showing
is the drug reaction that can be lethal.
The reactions called the Stevens- Johnson
syndrome and it can be particularly induced
by a drug Tegretol, which is used commonly.
But now we know the gene that predicts this
and we can prevent someone from dying or having
to be so sick from this.
Because one genotype, one basic analysis can
solve that problem.
And then just last week, I had a op-ed in
the New York Times about statins.
I don’t know if you’re familiar with statins,
it’s the most commonly used prescription
drug.
But unfortunately, it’s overdosing the country
and the side effect of diabetes has been underplayed.
And this graph just shows that 1 in 255 people,
in respect of any statin that’s been looked
at, get diabetes from these drugs, in the
91,000 patients in all these different trials.
But what’s most particularly concerning are
the potent because these are the statins that
have the particular liability.
And these are like Crestor, Lipitor, high
doses of Simvastatin and those are the ones
to be on the look- out.
But yet, we don’t know the genes, the variation
of the genes that are accounting for this
problem.
Now one other area, just to touch on, about
digitizing people, and that’s imaging.
Now, the stethoscope was invented in 1816,
this is that cartoon of Rene Laennec and that
stethoscope doesn’t look like that anymore,
thank goodness.
It looks like this.
But we don’t need a stethoscope, for example,
to listen to the heart because we have a portable,
high resolution ultra sound device that fits
right in the pocket better than a stethoscope.
And this device, and in just a minute, you
can capture exactly what the heart looks like.
And this is, uh, you know, an amazing tool
because we can basically digitize the person’s
heart in a minute or two, and no longer are
we listening to “lub dub” which isn’t really
that informative when you can see everything.
This is a normal heart, and here’s an example
of a very sick heart, where you see much less
ability of the heart muscle to contract, all
the chambers of the heart are very dilated,
there’s a lot less blood flow moving.
Just to give you a sense, these are images
that are acquired in a minute and they can
be not just of the heart, the abdomen, they
can be of the fetus, for a pregnant woman.
All sorts of things that we can do, we couldn’t
do just a year or two ago.
The thing that perhaps you might find the
most interesting, perhaps scary, is the ability
to read your mind.
And the idea that we can read, see the movies
in your brain.
You say, “Well, that can’t possibly be.”
And about imagining, this is not just mind
boggling, this is mind blowing.
This is now the ability to construct brain
activation maps from functional magnetic residents
imagining of the brain.
And we can digitize brains, and best exemplified
by this UC Berkley study published last fall,
where they took people, young people like
you, put them in a magnetic residence imagining,
showed them a U2 video, and then they without
any knowledge of the video they tried to construct
what the individual was seeing in their brain.
This is what it looked like.
You say, “Well, that doesn’t really like
Steve Martin.” Or, “It doesn’t look like
that.” But you know what, that’s pretty
good not knowing anything about the video.
And this is, you know, vintage 2011.
What’s that gonna look like in 2013 or 2015?
And they just recently published the same
sort of thing with auditory signals they can
reconstruct the music or whatever the sound
was through the same type of technique.
So, I just wanna, last couple minutes, put
this together.
This is the, uh, crack to try to get in your
mind.
This is why people die; they have a crack
in their artery.
Whether it’s a crack in their artery of their
heart or to their brain that causes a stroke.
And a crack is something we haven’t been
able to diagnose.
This is, has been elusive.
We haven’t been able to digitize the people
who are gonna have a crack.
Uh, Tim Russert was in the NBC studio and
he collapsed, had a massive heart attack.
But two weeks before that he had a normal
treadmill test, common scenario.
Now why did that happen and why is it so common?
Because we do these treadmill tests all the
time, but they only tell us if there’s a
tight narrowing that’s blocking the blood
supply.
Most cracks occur where there isn’t a tight
narrowing, and we haven’t had any way to
diagnose that.
Well now, we have done a study where, in the
San Diego area, we’ve had all of the heart
attack people, we got blood samples in the
early minutes to find the cells that were
sloughing off from their artery.
We found them, identified them, sequenced
them and have all kinds of genomics that we’ve
done and we’ve shown that that is a unique
signature that we can detect.
And, in fact, we’re publishing on that in
just a couple weeks in a leading journal.
So, this is important because then we can
combine this and develop within embedded sensor.
We have all these embedded sensors in our
car, well, I think our bodies are more important
than our car.
And you probably take all that stuff for granted
because you’ve never been sick.
But, those of us that have been sick would
like to have an embedded sensor to prevent
significant illness.
And this is a chip that was just published
on at Stanford, not far away of course.
A microchip that you can put in the blood
to detect whatever you want, we have also
been working on a nanochip the size of a gran--,
grain of sand just like this.
You take the grain of sand nano sensor and
you put it in the blood, like in the wrist,
and then you have this molecular signature
of a heart attack, and guess what you have?
You have the new app for heart attack.
Or, alternatively, an app for detecting the
first cancer cell in the blood, since most
cancers have a vascular supply.
And, of course, for diabetes it takes five
years to become a diabetic that is, uh, immune-mediated
diabetes you could detect in that five year
stretch to prevent diabetes, or prevent things
like a transplant rejection.
Here is a cell phone, becoming center stage
for the future of health because of this embedded
sensor capability.
So, the last thing that I just want to mention
is consumers needing to drive this.
That’s actually why I put this book together.
Because this is a real opportunity that would
be left in a stasis mode unless we get moving.
And, uh, to me it’s just remarkable.
This is in January in the Wall Street Journal
and it was a survey report of physicians using
e-mail.
E-mail’s been around a long time, even before
Google.
[Laughs]
>>Eric Topol: And I’ve been using e-mail
with patients since ninety, I don’t know,
‘93,’94.
I don’t what, you know.
This is amazing, we had had 62% of physicians
refuse to use e-mail with their patients,
today, it’s 2012.
This is an amazing article from JAMA, the
leading journal in medicine.
It says, “Should patients have access to
their laboratory tests?” Well, sorry to say
it’s their laboratory tests, how can they
ask this question?
How about this one?
This is, “Should patients have access to
their office notes, from the doctor?” How
could you ask that question?
Just because it might say in the note, that
the patient, that, uh, had something about
SOB and it means shortness of breath, you
know, eventually the person should figure
that out, of course, maybe need a little bit
of guidance.
There’s this fellow, who is in the Bay area,
Hugo Campos, who has a defibrillator, he just
wants to get his data of his heart rhythm
from the company and they won’t let him have
it.
And, he’s on a tear, appropriately, he should
get his data.
And then the worst of all is the American
Medical Association.
They are lobbying the government to prevent
people from getting there DNA data.
They only want doctors to be the ones to privy
to that data to mediate giving that to patients.
Which, of course, that’s not, that’s I think,
violating the rights of the individuals.
So that’s the right to the emergence of citizen
scientists.
And that’s, I think, a great thing.
And this just came out.
I just saw this this morning.
This is a group at McGill in Canada, and they
have gamified, uh, the use of sequencing.
It’s very difficult to align sequences, and
they made it into a game, a video game, and
they have found that people with no scientific
background could actually figure out how to
align sequences and make it into a fun puzzle,
and that’s amazing.
Just to me, that you could take these sequences
and make it into a game to assemble genomes.
And that kind of gives you a sense of where
the world could go.
So, I leave you with this last, uh, thought,
which is that, it’s your charts, office notes,
your laboratory tests, your scan results,
your bio sensor data, your DNA, your tissue,
your social network, that’s the way medicine
should be.
And since all this data is gonna be now going
into high gear, your ability to access it,
this is, uh, the time for the, the individual
to rise.
And that’s what’s gonna be necessary to
really execute the future of medicine.
So, I just, the whole thing putting it together,
we have this old Voltaire medicine today.
And we can change that by really bringing
together the new tools that I’ve reviewed
in digital medicine with the digital infrastructure.
And that could lead to super conversions,
the biggest in our history, and then of course,
to this new participatory precise medicine
of the future.
So I hope I can leave here with this concept
that was the whole goal, that the future is
indeed bright.
Thanks a lot for your attention.
[Applause]
>>male presenter: So what should ordinary
people, um, like non, non, uh, medical people
do?
Is it now up to us to somehow figure out that
we need to not sign the consent forms before
having our brain surgery until they change
it to say, “We will not put your tumor in
formaldehyde.”
>>Eric Topol: Yeah.
I think that, well if you, if you today demand
to your doctor that I want some of my specimen,
I want my mother’s specimen to be put in
freezer, they have to do that, so, but only
if you know about it.
So, that’s really part of the problem is
it isn’t even on the consent form, it’s
just a matter of knowledge.
And that is what we have a big problem, is
people just not aware of the opportunity that
exists today.
>>male #1: Are there, um, any sensors to do
with things coming into the body or what you’re
coming in contact with.
So, I would think, something that monitored
air quality, that monitored, monitored what
was in the food you ate, that monitored what
chemicals that came in contact with your skin,
and that way you could see correlations between
what people came in contact with and the actual
symptoms they had or the diseases they had.
>>Eric Topol: Yes, great point.
Um, so for asthma, a sensor of the future
that some people are working on, is one that
will pick up air quality as well as these
other things that you, put, um, you’d be
able to prevent an asthma attack, which, of
course, can be lethal particularly in children.
So that’s one example.
But you’re absolutely right, because, you
know what we take in our food stuff effects
our micro biome.
And so, for example, over lunch we were talking
about, “Is it all about a story of calories
in calories out?
Absolutely not because there’s a micro biome,
you know we have this, um, millions of different,
uh, bacterial flora organisms in our gut,
which are changed by our diet.
And also by taking antibiotics for example,
and that has an reaction of, in some people,
uh, pushing them towards obesity or changing
their metabolism, or making them at risk for
diabetes or other named diseases.
So you’re absolutely right, we need to get
that data, it’s not just what you excrete
or what makes you tick.
It’s also your exposome, your environment.
And that includes food, you know, um, air
and your water, all those sorts of things.
So it’s a great point.
Thank you.
Yeah.
>>male #2: Uh, in the uh, early 2000’s, I
asked a family friend who’s also a doctor,
about the fad that came out at that time about
doing whole body MRI scans.
And, uh, and he basically said, “Don’t do
it.” He’s like, “The problem is that you’ll
find all sorts of things that are wrong with
you, that probably would do more harm than
good to treat.”
[Laughter]
>>Eric Topol: Yeah.
>>male #2: And I think we see the same thing
with like mammography, the recent debate that’s
been going on with that.
So, I guess this isn’t really a good argument
for not collecting the data, but it is, I
think, a need for how do you analyze it?
Or do you have any insights into where the
thresholds are for when you actually should
take action?
>>Eric Topol: Right, see you’re bringing
up some central concepts here.
The ability to, uh, engender the incidentalome,
where you basically back into findings just
because you shouldn’t have done the test
in the first place, that’s one thing.
So more judicious use of the right tests for
the right person, uh, you know, a lot of people
just sign up for the total body CAT scan and
their just asking for trouble.
And, like you also brought up with the mammography,
there’s a much higher rate of false biopsies,
positive biopsies and getting women and their
families, you know, horrified than there is
of preventing cancer.
So the odds of getting a true abnormal biopsy
is much lower than getting a false positive.
So these are, we need much more precise tools.
Who should get the studies or procedures?
And how to interpret them.
And part of it is this whole Bayesian thing
that the test or procedure is only good if
it’s being done on the right person.
Hopefully in the future we’re gonna pick
the right people and not have all these incidental
findings which wind up causing all kinds of
trouble.
>>male #2: So do you think, though, that it
is a matter of not having precise enough tools,
or could it be that even if you have all the
information you still are in a situation where
you’re not sure if it’s a problem or not?
>>Eric Topol: Well, that’s a great point.
Uh, I think it, a lot of it is the imprecision
of people having things done that just doesn’t
have any, it’s just, uh, this mass medicine
problem that we have today.
But there still is an issue, so for example,
when you have a whole genome sequence, you’re
doing it for, let’s say we’re trying to
unravel that 15-year-old girl’s story and
we find these other things in there that we
didn’t anticipate, what do we do with that?
See, whenever you have a lot of data, the
chance of you coming into things, uh, in unintended
way is gonna be there.
So this is an issue that has to be grappled
with.
You’re bringing up a very important, um,
concern.
Yeah.
>>female #1: Well on that note, thanks so
much for coming.
You left us with a lot to think about.
[laughs]
>>Eric Topol: Sure, Yeah.
>>female #1: Thanks.
>>Eric Topol: Thank you, thanks a lot.
[Applause]